so today we're starting one of the great
works of Western literature which some
of you I think may have read at one
point some of your classes and you may
read again in some of your other classes
Plato's Republic it's one of his longest
works we're not reading all of it we're
only reading four blocks
although books is kind of a strange
thing to call champions anyone know why
they call them books instead of chapters
through these ancient texts anybody ever
heard of this sort of thing what it
books look like before we had books that
for middle those are actually a
relatively modern invention think back
to like your Western Civ classes or or
Western history classes or world history
classes but people right on first you
remember yeah exactly yeah I mean first
they wrote on these these clay tablets
but those are very inconvenient aren't
they
you can only look at one page at a time
then they started using Scrolls and when
you see a text and it says you know
Republican it's got ten books but that
literally means is there were ten
Scrolls and your book was like a pouch
that had these scrolls in it and when
you wanted to read you know chapter
three you'd get out the third scroll and
scroll down and out of the computer
sense but it's not ancient sense and
you'd actually read it like this you'd
be turning one while you're turning the
other and you look at it and actually
all ancient books were that way until
the adventure
what we call the word Allah which is
what we used to the books of pages that
was the innovation we can always talk
more about why they did that later on
maybe I will tell you about that when we
get to Epictetus and Stoics so book 1 is
the first scroll and why did they get oh
stop it at book 1 that's how much you
could fit on a scroll so it was a
convenient unit of measure as you notice
that book 1 isn't all about one single
thing though right there's a couple of
different discussions and we're actually
not going to look at all those
discussions we're going to look at two
of the big ones mainly and we're going
to skip all the background material I
was going down to the PI Reyes and now
you know these guys caught up with me
and they started talking about horse
races and you know torches and all that
we're going to skip all of that because
that's that's nice background
information but it's not really
essential to to what we're doing here if
we're doing a play go class you know
I've just played all the whole semester
we might talk in greater detail about
that so you know with any dialogue just
like a play you've got a cast of
characters and so far what we've been
doing is you know one one character
Socrates gets up doesn't monologue talks
a little bit with latest write the
apology then we did the Credo and how
many people were there and that's kind
of a trick question how many of you
voices three right so credo Socrates and
the law is very good and Socrates you
know it's kind of a trick question
because Socrates is being like a
ventriloquist isn't he he's saying laws
would say this and then we used to throw
we're back to just two people talking
now we got a whole bunch of people
talking so I thought you might be good
to start with this just to introduce you
to these characters so you have someone
here who's
because one of the skills that I want
you to have reading these things is
figuring out who is actually saying one
who was taking one position it is easy
to mix these pieces with these different
people up again you know confuses
Socrates talking here or is this
precipitous Tristram against this
position what is Socrates actual
position so Socrates I don't need to
talk about him you'd already know him
right
you've gotten to know him a little bit
catalase is an old man and all of this
dialogue actually takes place at the
house of catalase he is the one who's
hosting the party he talks a little bit
at the very start with Socrates as
Socrates you never come to visit me
anymore and Socrates and him get into a
discussion about in a whole-day age and
his old age good or bad
and then as soon as Socrates raises the
key question for the whole walk the
whole of the Republic capitalism does
the prudent thinking he says well I
think I gotta go and check on the dinner
I'm gonna go and leave that leave this
stuff to you and he says homework is you
in here at the argument we pull Marcos
that's his son and quite as fun as his
other son quite a fun doesn't talk much
Paul Marcus does that's so much and then
if Socrates is hanging out with Dad Anna
Manzo's Adam antis and Vulcan are
brothers too so Socrates is kind of a
middle-aged man these are all young men
these are those young men that Socrates
is corrupting who are learning how to
argue from him who are picking up on his
example some of these are mentioned
illegally in the apology you know
Socrates is saying hey if you think I'm
screwing these kids up so badly why
don't you actually bring some of them
and take a look at and see if they're
any good and if you read through the
Republic you will see that these are
good young men they have their head on
straight
this guy's a different story
certificates certificates is not from
anthems he is through Simba kiss
Chalcedon or confidante when it was I
think it would be how it would be
pronounced he is sort of a gun for hire
except he doesn't doesn't fight with you
know swords or anything like that he
fights with words he is what you call a
sophist one of these people who Socrates
got confused with who makes the worst
argument appear the stronger who teaches
people how to argue well so as to win
and is not particularly concerned about
what's true or who's actually right or
anything like that you might think it's
like a debate coach or any of you had
two big teams in high school it was
really interesting I worked with the
debate team of Bennett at FSU and I
found out that debate has nothing to do
these days whether right or wrong or
even who's got the better argument they
just learn how to do talking points and
[ __ ] about quick right how many listen
to me you're like wow that doesn't even
make any sense
but the judges sometimes get convinced
throw Civic is would have been one of
those people training them and through
Civic has has some very definite ideas
about things and he lets you know he
also has a you might say a character or
a way of presenting himself that
replicates the position on justice that
he's going forward so all of you who
read the read the Republic
what's this kind of like this Turkish
guy pick some adjectives or we're now
calling this map
yeah he's rude yeah I mean he says you
know Socrates you know aren't you
finished you know weaning from your wet
nurse she's a white girl you're you know
dripping nose that's not very nice isn't
it
but you say something like that says
somebody that you're having a discussion
with and did it across the table
some people do I've been at dinner party
what else what else can you say about
this guy Basin way to remember from what
you read yeah yeah what makes you say
that he's selfish okay that's very good
he's selfish in one way which is that he
wants to do a monologue rather than die
he wants to like Socrates says through
seven gates you know poured this over us
like somebody pouring water a flood and
then then he's ready to sit well okay I
said my presenting I'm gonna go and you
all know people like that they want to
tell you their opinion and then when you
want to talk about your own views
conversation is done all right that's
selfish is he selfish in any other ways
yeah close minded that's interesting how
cozy close-minded it's full of himself
yeah I mean he thinks that he knows and
everyone else is stupid or foolish weak
kind of just like like he's not even
money there's no really other way to put
it and I think just yeah he is he's he's
an ass we you know we have all sorts of
words for people like this you know one
of the fancy words he's a poor you know
he's boorish right we don't use that
word anymore we use more right language
to describe people like that but it's
the same idea and people like that exist
in every society and every time it is an
interesting case I'll tell you another
way you solve it you guys might not have
picked up on it he wants them to ping
him it's a talk if you want Socrates to
pay him so they're having a conversation
and now I have actually pulled something
like this out of desperation at that
times because when people find out that
I teach philosophy the first thing they
want to do is tell me all about their
philosophy and they want to you know
pick my brain and sometimes they just
want to argue and I don't like to argue
with people so I started saying you know
I don't give away product for free I I
get paid to do this
and you know here's my our hourly rate
and I always quote something really high
and then they leave me alone I got a
plane or training usually I don't have
to do that but there's some I guess is
actually serious
even when Socrates to pay him and
Socrates ends up you know then this goes
to your idea of selfishness socrates
ends up saying well I don't have any
money but I'll give you some praise I'll
make you feel good and through Semak is
can't grudgingly a sense - that doesn't
mean that's kind of a jerky thing to do
- isn't it to be at somebody else's
house and say I'm not going to talk to
you guys and say pay me but it fits in
with his philosophy as we're gonna see
what's really interesting about this guy
is despite what a jerk he is after
Socrates beats him he sticks around
through the rest of the Republic he
doesn't say anything he seems to have
changed his mind about his own views and
behavior and he's there to learn and we
can explore that later someone some
other time but just keep that in the
back in line he's not all bad but you
know he is there there's something wrong
with him something wrong with his ideas
so let's look at some of that but before
we do that there's somebody else to talk
about
I'm not gonna talk about capitalist you
guys read as arguments about an old age
this is not something that you think
about very much right because you're all
young I don't imagine that any of you
extreme sitting inside your retirement
portfolio yeah I know but that's because
I have been working at it for a while
and I'm middle-aged I'm starting to look
at that Arnold Schwarzenegger this is
kind of a tangent that it kind of puts
things in perspective one of the reasons
he wanted to come to America years and
years and years ago was back in his
country in Austria people your age you
know moving into their 20s
we're already starting to talk about
their retirement and he found that so
incredibly boring you know he thought
what the hell kind of place is this
where young people are you know like
just looking way way off another horizon
at this stuff that's not gonna happen
for years and years and they're not
actually living their life now so it's
not surprising to find out that you're
not you know thinking about doing it
wealth and old age doesn't do any virtue
in old age but you can think about these
things now you know in order for you to
enjoy yourself now most of you don't
have to worry about health like you will
when you're old but you do need money
don't you there's money enough you gotta
have a really good time with money buy
all sorts of things
one to have money to shop you can go to
bars you know it's kind of nice to go to
a fancy restaurant not have to worry
about the cost you know or if you want
to take a cab take it what else my
friends for a while total money runs out
there's money enough you guys already
have you know a wealth of experience
don't no pun intended with that Yuval
you see people with money and how they
pay does money make people particularly
happy no it's good to have though it's
harder than it's harder to be happy
without some sort of money or right why
doesn't it enough the other way
capitalist is getting it what else is he
thinking yeah of course he's at the end
of his life he's worried about the
afterlife you can be read the end of
your life and you got maybe five more
years to live and there is it have it in
the hell
what do you start worrying about make it
more money what are you still worrying
about some people might even worry about
that now yeah I mean by the time that
you're sixty you've done something wrong
probably a whole bunch of things you
know and you start to think about what's
gonna be waiting for you and a great
beyond
a lot of people are able to put those
things off for a while and drink it away
or play it away or chat it away but when
you get closer and closer to the end
these things have a way of coming back
up to want you even on this side of this
great world abide and people start
worrying
they might even just worry what's my
legacy gonna be here so that's this
world but a lot of them start worrying
about what's gonna happen later on
what's that big stuff you know we'll
think about our are sort of you know
traditional schema here where we you
know we're mostly monotheistic religions
in this country we tend to say there's a
good place in a bad place what gets you
in the door loitering all right I'm not
going to hell I got the lucky number is
that how it works all the money can't
buy it again
what can see is a good place or sends
you down a bad place exactly what you do
and what the quality of what they do is
if you do enough good deeds you're a
good person you do enough bad deeds you
become a bad person
howls for bad people that one's for good
people there's a problem you know what
what if you're coming in between you
know there's a lot of questions about
yeah let's assume it's pretty simple
well you know that's something
capitalist is concerned we're not that
concerned with that though right now all
right
even I have a minute I'm only 41 so for
worrying more about it when I'm 61 so
capitalist leaves and polemarchus takes
over that Paul Marcus is going to try to
answer this big question that Socrates
is asking him this is what the whole
book of the Republic is about what is
justice how do we know what is right and
wrong do we have a definition for
justice but it can't be something just
like whatever makes me feel good
whatever it makes me feel warm and fuzzy
all right
that wouldn't be justice that's what
makes me feel good that's something
different
so what is justice there's a lot of
answers to this we're gonna see a couple
different answers just in this book of
the Republic and an next class session
we're going to see another answer and
when we look at before Socrates is
actually gonna tell us what his position
is here he's just you know mostly
attacking other people's positions
Marcus you've all heard an eye for an
eye tooth for a tooth right does that I
mean is there something satisfying about
them somebody hurts you they deserve to
be heard right justice is about
deserving
I'm giving people
what they deserve and we're going to
look at some of the arguments that are
in that are actually made here how do
you know what people deserve well you
know they start out talking about cases
that are really easy to think about I
give you something and I say I want you
to hold on to this for me and when I
want it back from you please give it
back to me
I use money or a weapon or I know what
you think of all sorts of things maybe
some food maybe the family member you
know maybe my car and and if you give it
back to me that's paying one for you all
that's giving me back what you have for
me and you owe me right if I lend you
some money
I expect that money to come back to me
someday yeah you know why do we charge
interest on if you lend so many money if
you feel like you know how to make it
worth your while
I hope you do could any of you have bank
accounts do you tell the bank I don't
need the interest they don't say in the
face of everything and they pay a lot
less interest than they will will charge
you why is it okay for them to charge
interest just because they can because
we're using their service yeah you're
making use of somebody else's things so
it makes sense you know if if I let you
to use my field to farm your crops maybe
you should give me something across
maybe that's what's fair this is tied in
with sort of a notion of fairness too
isn't it
you could think of it in other ways I
bring in coffee one day
you know like I go to Starbucks and I
get one of those big boxes of coffee and
put it up here I say okay anybody who
wants coffee
come on oh let's say all of you like
coffee and I say okay criteria tall
people get two cups of coffee short
people get only one cup of coffee
arbiter is a little a little arbitrary
so you get a another cup of coffee
think you qualify as tall right so you
get another cup of coffee boss is tall
in here the rest of you don't you don't
me get one cup of coffee is that fair
and I get and I get two cups too because
I'm tall and then I get myself an extra
cup and then maybe I get another cup
because I'm over 40 for 200 I got I've
got like 10 cups of coffee and do you
want now that we've lost the sense of
fairness along the way haven't we
giving people what they deserve
there has to be some sort of measure
doesn't there
and so Paul Marcus is is he's putting
something out there that seems pretty
common sensical it's something that we
see in lots of different societies this
makes them some sense jives with our
experience doesn't it there are some
problems with it and here's where we get
too many arguments socrates raises one
big problem right off the bat and you
can think about this if anything like
this if I give you my gun and I say to
you I want you to hold on to this gun
for a baby I don't wanna go
right right right now I have before but
I don't know currently I'm not auntie
Gunnar
not now I come to you in the middle of
the night and I love math and I say you
know that SOB
I'm going to kill him I need my gun now
is it right for you to give me the
gunner is it isn't it wrong for you to
give me the gun I mean what did what is
what is justice saying you owe me that
gun don't you see so many timing has
somebody you're shaking your hands why
are you shaking your head I wonder why
wouldn't it be just good yeah so maybe
maybe there could be cases where you
shouldn't give the person back what they
owe let's say you know that somebody's
got a drunk you have it and you're their
their banker maybe you shouldn't give
them their money back clean
you know let's say somebody has a prize
record collection and they're a terrible
depressed state and they have lent it to
you and you know they're gonna break it
because they get it you know they get
something out of destroying things when
they're feeling bad hold on to it but
you notice this is one of those it
starts to get tough doesn't it it seems
like it well on the one hand it's just
that on the other hand it's not just
this is where we get to something that
we call a
contradictions we have a contradiction
you're saying that something is the case
and at the same time something is and if
you can take the same thing and say that
it is this way and it's also not resume
somewhere along the line you must have
made a mistake think about mathematics
mathematics is really simple this way if
somewhere along the line you arrive at
the result of two plus two eight three
you made a mistake somewhere right
because the two plus two isn't three
it's what we said five
nobody said 18 right in that case
there's a lot of different ways but
seems where you go wrong the other 10
plus we had before or it doesn't April 4
it can't be both unless you this this
code can't be both described bluish
black maybe and orange at the same time
unless of course it had maybe stripes
right then it's a stripe to come and
then you could still say about each part
each part each stripe is either orange
or it's blue it can't be both they might
get you know it's one of those kind of
fabrics where it changes you know the
way it looks in the light holographic
fabrics well is it still you know it
depends on whether you're looking at it
this way or this way it's still not two
different colors at the same time right
in the same place so if you can get to
the point which Socrates is trying to
get to where any action is both just and
unjust there must be some mistake along
the way that's why the country
because that's what's gonna happen in
his arguments whole market says well
yeah okay so yeah I get what you're
saying don't give the the crazy person
who's got a sword or you know whatever
is going to do but what's the thing
about more common you know examples what
do you owe to people and you're just
really so giving people what they know
or what they deserve let's forget about
like the things that people have lent
you or anything what do you think people
deserve respect
okay does everybody deserve respect if
they respect respect it's harder it's a
lot harder to respect someone that's a
factual statement about our emotions it
is harder to respect somebody who
doesn't respect us should you do you
have a duty to respect them even if they
don't respect you nobody Hitler should
you respect Hitler if he shows up again
let's take the ultimate man yeah yeah me
good stuff in a whole bunch of other
yeah
Stalin was was just as thoroughly evil
as Hitler was those moths had done so it
was Pol Pot you know you can rack up
these people or even we just take you
know sort of small grant serial killers
Jeffrey Dahmer he shows up he's dead
yeah video respected I mean respect
himself certainly did respect his
victims the drill holes it to their
heads trying to turn them into zombies
that's how we killed them trying to have
them into slaves for all sorts of
terrible things for he's from my home
city well you know that's that's a good
question
why is it harder to respect somebody who
doesn't respect us because on some level
we feel that they they don't deserve it
right maybe they deserve something
differently
Paul Marcus talks about in terms of
friends and enemies this you know we
don't often think of people as being our
enemy except you know maybe in other
countries or things like that but all of
you have friends and all of you have
enemies
all of you have friends there's probably
different reasons why you're friends
with this person as opposed to this
person as opposed to this person so in
general what can you say about your
friends they're actually your friends
together - yeah there's certain
behavioral requirements they should it's
really nice to you it may not always be
nice I mean I've been the president
people where we call each other names
and stuff like that but it was all that
and fun yeah it's like when they're not
serious about like you know like they're
never like actually yeah and I mean you
can actually have relationships where
that's where this fake meanness can seem
really mean to people on the outside but
it can actually be something that brings
people together so inserting the game -
what should they feel towards you if
they're really your friend
okay that's that's our different they
should be loyal fades moment you should
probably have some evidence of them you
know you you get to be friends sometimes
with people by going through situations
where they get tested okay that's very
good
- they're open maybe they also keep your
secrets something else I'm trying to get
at how many often they feel towards what
should they desire for you
yeah those yeah and successes in the
class that's a good way to put it they
hope the best for you they hope good
things for you they want you to prosper
they want you to feel you know safe they
want you to feel okay they want good
things for you that's a mix of friends
what makes somebody an enemy it's not
just doing bad things to you and
somebody who talks behind your back
they're an enemy to you why well because
they desire to harm you why do people
talk about other people behind their
back they want to hurt them you know the
person who pushes you down you know
on the playground there an enemy -
they're just an open enemy somebody who
talks to you all the time as if you're
worth nothing they're an enemy they they
don't like you they may even hate you
right that's an enemy you you actually
do have a we even have this this word
that got coined like 10 years ago
frenemy it's a combination person who
you think is a friend and so you keep
him close to you but you know you also
know you really can't trust them they're
they're really your your undermine you
okay so what what do you owe to friends
the ages are good things for you you're
not a very good friend if you don't
dislike it then yeah right yeah I was
gonna say to return the favor
everything they provide yeah you should
be giving good things to friends to be
just if you if people treat you well
that you treat them poorly in return
Paul Marcus will say you're a bad person
you're a user
we don't be like that they don't stay
friends with people for very long what
can you give to your enemies to give
them good things should you do this Paul
Marcus not not what you feel in your
heart of hearts should you give them
respect no you should try to kill them
if you can that's what they deserve you
should burn their houses and you know
drive them out of town and undermine
their businesses and do whatever you can
to them because they're our enemies you
give them bad things or evil
others there's two real problems with
this one Socrates brings up this is a
very attractive viewpoint is that this
makes sense I mean we may not want to
cop to it means we may want to think of
ourselves as being nice but this
actually does make sense in every
society there's one big problem though
are we always correct in our assessments
about who our friends or enemies
actually are think about your own
experience how many of you have been
screwed over but by somebody at one
point in time okay you've had the
experience with thinking that somebody
was your friend and they turned out to
be your enemy right have you ever had
the other experience where you you
didn't get along with somebody you
thought their and they were just you
know scum and then after a while you
come to realize hey I kind of like this
person that's there there's not
something wrong with me because I like
this person I've actually just come to
realize their their good qualities make
movies about this don't we you know the
two warriors from you know different
civilizations stranded on the desert
island and they find they have to work
together and they actually turn out to
be very similar you know this one's got
a family back home this one's got a
family back home well they tell them
they can actually be friends they can
trust each other now let's go a little
bit further with this I think back to
that example where you've asked for it
over
you were probably giving that for some
good things right that was the right
thing for you to do in one sense except
for the fact that they were actually
your enemy so what should you do
should have been giving them bad things
so you should have been giving them good
things and bad things at the same time
we got a contradiction the problem is we
don't actually know all the time who is
actually good and it was actually bad
sometimes we are friends with people who
are really bad then you know some you
know one of the things that you have to
go through in your life is the problem
many times it's cutting people off
saying I'm done with this person you
know they're they're no good for they're
toxic
there so that's one problem with this
the other problem that Socrates racism
maybe this goes to this notion of giving
everybody respect if we if you have to
do harm your enemies are you making them
better you're making them worse than
harming them as a human being put aside
any ideas that they might learn a lesson
because you know there could be a good
point to punish them punishment is when
you can flick someone they had the thing
on somebody minutes to try to make them
better but if you're just you know
attacking your enemy are you making them
a better person probably making it worse
right making it more angry or hateful
giving them more reasons you know fuel
off by themselves so could it really be
justice for you to damage another person
then with a just person is really an Adu
Socrates in Aeschylus I think that your
position is very similar to Socrates
position that you should show everybody
respect Socrates would actually say that
pretty tough to do though is it with
some people emotionally
so this is this is these are some
problems of this position let's go on to
through semi cos so what it's persimmon
Cass say justice he's much more rational
he says all that nonsense about friends
and that sort of stuff forget what is
justice do you remember the formula
you keep saying over and over again
interest the interest or what's good for
the stronger exactly so justice Socrates
that screws with him a little bit that
says it mean you mean the biggest guy in
the room one of them is they eat the
most meat why don't you carry the most
it's their interest and certificates you
know this is where he starts to get kind
of cocky isn't it you know that is not
what I'm talking about at all and you
know it what I mean is that people who
are in charge stronger alert the rulers
impose their will what we call subjects
and those are the weaker so you know the
cop cop has the gun the cop has the
billy club and the cop can haul you into
jail cop gets to decide what counts is
right and wrong not you know when you
have your own you know billy club and
gun and and you know your own legal
system behind you then you get to do it
right then you get through stronger
in a relationship we could think about
this not necessarily in terms of
governments or things like that
mr. Simmons does you some of you and
probably sure had some parents that were
very caring and rational and probably
some of you have parents who said smiley
or the highway and you know when you
have your own house you can make your
own rules but I'm in charge so you're
going to live by my rules
that's interest of the stronger and you
can you probably said that sucks that's
you know BS this this isn't fair and so
I wouldn't care what's fair I'll tell
you what's fair that's they get to
decide the justices they get to decide
what what counts as and you notice it
always does line up in these sort of
cases with the interest in the stronger
it's what works out well for them you
don't get to play your music real loud
when they have to you know go to work or
want to watch TV it sucks but you get to
listen to it it really matters to me
I remember going through this path as a
kid back then it was boom boxes and you
get trouble and you could say well you
don't I should get my time to listen to
stuff do you listen to your TV and it's
real loud or you know why why don't have
to go to bed when you want to go to bed
because they're the stronger they're in
charge they call the shots
how come you get to drink and I don't
get to drink well you know they'd say
well first of all you're not 21 but then
they say because it's my house and I
bought the stuff I get to drink it not
you you know the interest of the
stronger what about in in relationships
when you're you know with
somebody's who you think your equal with
so people ever dominate each other
friends or you know dating relationships
you've seen that right
bullying is a good example of this
abusive relationships are a good example
of this so you know you can see this
happen in a lot of cases and they get to
decide what counts as right as just as
good the stronger gets it dominate and
they get to push their values and their
views onto the weaker and often times
people will say stuff like well that's
the way of the world or you know that's
just the way it goes
or life isn't fair they're endorsing of
you sort of like this where they say
might makes right they'll order that one
right those who have power get to use it
on those who don't and if you don't like
it what should you do you don't like
being dominated being pushed around by
other people yeah what is it what is
that going to mean effectively though
just push them away and no you gonna
push them down you got to become
powerful yourself you don't want other
people that oppose their values on you
become so powerful that you can impose
your values on other people cuz that's
the real test for power at this sort of
mentality now there's I mean how many of
you like this nobody wants to counter
that there's always you know
like this how many of you really don't
like this a lot of feelings that way
either you're okay with people
dominating you and pushing their values
on you and not giving you a chance to
grow and develop your own really I doubt
it but you don't feel too good when
people do that to you
but that's feelings can we think of any
reasons why this can't actually be the
right way that's what Socrates is 50 of
us because they've given us reasons
so let's actually look at some of these
these arguments these are actually on
the handout that I have put into
alluring for you so you can if you don't
get them quite right now through there
for you it's from the short form so if
this is justice then the right thing to
do for those who don't have power with
you what not rise up powers we'll make
the rules your little people what should
you do
what makes a good person that in that
case get rules in place they may not
actually be you know the best rules but
the rules
it makes a good person what makes you a
bad person yeah so what makes you the
bad person to break the rules then what
makes a good person follow the rules and
the rules may not make sense because you
know some powerful person just made them
maybe there may be the powerful person
is screwed up
we don't know definitely they made the
rules to favor them so if the powerful
person says we don't like philosophers
everybody should get together you know
once a day and hate philosophers you
guys remember that any of you reads I
have native art bless you that book 1984
by George Orwell so there's it's a
totalitarian society it's what you call
it dystrophy it's a bad place and people
who are in charge of really powerful
they manipulate all sorts of things
behind the scene and they have a thing
each day and I don't remember what it's
called like a hate the Russian or you
know hate party and they get together
and they flash images of these people on
the screen and you're supposed to hate
them and shout at them and this
solidifies their their power
imagine we did this with with race we
did this with nationality let's say the
rulers really liked them they wanted us
to kind of tough society
racism nationalities would be hard to
not transgress against somebody I don't
know well China's our big strategic
right the rest of your lifetime you're
going to be hearing a lot about China
because they're rising and were sort of
sitting still and they're going to be
the next superpower
maybe we should hate the Chinese maybe
we will have leaders who say everybody
here better start getting Chinese if
you're Chinese that poses some problems
for you right maybe then you just
disassociate and say I'm one of the good
Chinese I don't want a bad Chinese well
if that's the case then doing what the
ruler is saying even though this seems
kind of screwy to us that becomes the
existing to do it serves the rulers
interest doesn't define society here's a
problem what if the rulers don't
actually know what's good for them let's
say one of us sets up society and sets
up the rules of right and wrong and well
you know if you put me in charge should
because I'd make some dumb mistakes you
know I'm smart enough to know that I
wouldn't make those mistakes
because I actually happen to charge of
some things you know I mean tell
mistakes when I was in charge of those
occasionally you know I would be tempted
to if you gave me absolute power I would
be tempted to use that power just to
further my own interests and then screw
over other people and that probably
would benefit you I would probably be
sadder when I currently happen you know
because I wouldn't have any incentive to
try to get back in shape or diet or
anything like that and you know I'd be
eating the sort of stuff that they make
over at the culinary all the time really
rich desserts and something like that
now if I made the rules so that all of
you are supposed to you know just give
me as much pleasure as possible in my
life and I'm in charge that would in one
way be the right thing for you to do
right because I'm commanding it but
would it really be in my interests this
is what has happened a lot of times
throughout history so you never
contradiction there you'd be doing one
action and it would be both right and
wrong at the same time now through Simba
kiss gets around this he says you know
I'm not talking about that sort of case
I'm talking about where the rulers
actually know what they're doing where
they're good rulers in the sense of
they're they're following what ruling is
about they don't make stupid mistakes
like and I'm pursuing pleasure or you
know killing all their enemies or things
like that
this is where Socrates comes up with an
interesting name and I'll put it over
here so this is soccer
you think about medicine or piloting a
boat or anything you like anything that
has enforceable what does that skill
Amen that's different things right
medicine teams that what's the goal for
medicine curing diseases and when when
the diseases have been cured we have a
state of that we call health very good
as opposed to sickness when you're
piloting a boat don't crash on the rocks
right you're a good pilot if you don't
crash
you're a bad pilot if you if you do just
like if you're a bad doctor the patients
patients tend to die if you're good let
me get better right you can think of all
sorts of cases like this all you are
going to major in something all right
all of you presumably are going to have
some sort of skill by the time that you
get out of here and hopefully you're
actually good at that because if you're
not but then your clients are going to
be kind of irritated with you when they
you know want you to do this and you
screw it up
right you want your clients to be happy
with you what are these skills aim after
they all aim after a certain kind of
good certain tenets what he calls
perfection so you know the medicine the
doctor they try to heal you they try to
make you healthy now the skill tells the
so are already do considering medicine
you're like pre-med - okay anybody going
into business like finance marketing
what else is big here criminal justice
anybody go into criminal justice okay
psychology sociology things like that
all of these you have things that
they're about all these kind of goals
all these have skills in criminal
justice
keep the prisoners actually in the
prison until they're ready to come out
that's a pretty basic goal if it doesn't
happen we're all in a lot of trouble
keep the patients alive you know manage
the money supply build good businesses
these are all important thing and the
skill tells the practitioner what to do
doesn't matter I mean do you trust
anybody who says I'm gonna do doctoring
based on my own ideas I've got this
system here anybody since whenever
somebody starts out a conversation I've
got this system that I came up with run
because it's probably gonna be bad for
you for every like you know one one
person who actually has a good working
system that they came up with on their
own
that actually turns out to be true and
work well there's a million coops and if
you put your money with that or you put
your health in their hands or you put
your relationship in their hands we
think about anyone who's going into
psychiatry or psychology you're also
about healing people but their psyche is
telling them how to manage their lives
you want to have any actual skill
telling the practitioners what to do is
that what the practitioners do they work
on the ordinary person and still has
actually some way the stronger compared
to the practitioner who's weaker isn't
it they're telling the practitioner what
to do the skill never fails the
practitioner may fail when the
practitioner is stronger
and the person that they're dealing with
is right there every once in a while I
go to the doctor's office and they they
tell me I have a high blood pressure
that's usually because I drank like two
two pots of coffee and you know didn't
eat anything that day and then I
explained that to them and they say yeah
we've heard all those excuses before a
whole bunch of people come in here and
tell us those those sort of stories
we're gonna check your blood pressure
daily this is it happen to be a couple
times you know I'm going for like you
know I'm a sinus infection they're gonna
check your blood pressure because they
always do now you're on their radar and
they're gonna charge aren't they if you
don't do what your doctor tells you
you're in trouble you know your stock
think of or we could think about prisons
right I mean there are prisons that Eric
should run well where they're trying to
make the prisoners into people who can
let out and not have to worry about
who's in charge there it's not the
prisoners cigars the administration now
here's the question that usually ask in
terms of the truce images your syndicate
is saying that this is set up just so
that these people can exploit these
people is that how it really works let's
think about some professions are there
any doctors who exploit their patients
you read stories about them every once
in a while don't you can you think of
any ways doctors exploit their patients
sometimes
oh that's a big one yeah without their
consent I mean there were terrible
things that were done to people years
ago I probably still being done in other
countries you know injecting them with
diseases just to see what would happen
you know that's somebody to explain
somebody else
what else do you think of any other kids
yeah yeah that's another good I had a
friend who was a doctor and I was
looking for another job I was thinking
about changing my profession and how we
see these drug reps going in and out of
his office and so I asked him what would
it take for me to be a drug rep but I
need like a degree in chemistry or
pharmacy or something like that
you just gotta be a Salesman they'll
send you to seminars and you know you'll
learn about that drug that you're
representing and that's why I don't buy
anything from these people because they
don't know anything you know they'll
take you know they'll take the doctors
out wine and dine up and take them to
all these nice vacation spots and then
what's the doctors supposed to do at the
turn prescribed that drug and the Raps
unfortunate this is what my friend who's
if I could even like them used to be
that then if you had like a chemistry
person or a pharmacy person or biology
person they would they wouldn't have
that drug and they could tell you what
it would interact with these people who
are doing drug drug reppin now they do
they have no idea though
so you'd ask them well can I prescribe
this with this before you guys pose
why not you know what that leads to
maybe your doctor is prescribing you
whatever drug they are not because it's
because they're going to
get back there there are cases better
sure yeah
there are cases where people do exploit
each other based on their you know
standing that they have politicians do
this right you know we can all think of
corruption politicians that you know
give favours to the people that do
favors for them that treat the ordinary
person pretty poorly we've all seen that
sort of thing happen but here's the
question you got to ask through some
against the saying okay that's the way
it is that's the way it ought to be
Socrates is saying if you're actually
being guided by this profession think
about doctors again if you're really
following the rules of your profession
would you prescribe a drug that you you
are just getting paid money to prescribe
that a drug company is taking out to
dinner and you know tell rooms to
prescribe them is that what your what
your skill would tell you to do
yes or no no you would be following it
with the building hands and you wouldn't
be exploiting for people who are weaker
your if you're actually following your
skill you're working for those people
you are trying to help them out you're
working for their interest not the
interest of the stronger the interests
of the weaker now here's the question
you have to ask yourself with medicine
okay it's really easy right medicine is
all about healing what's the purpose of
ruling of governing who's had an
election over in Ulster County I don't
know if you guys have one over here in
Dutchess County why don't we go to the
polls and elect people
your father could be like where they
look okay electing your personal
business you just have like you know
crazy views or you know they're not tied
to what's good or what's bad what are
your personal views about them they're
about your work
these your interests what's good for you
or also you mean you might not you be so
selfish still only care but what's good
for you you might care about what's good
for mom dad brother and sister you know
why do the bit your friends your
community you might care about the
interests of other people and so the art
of ruling the skill of ruling would be
about doing what's good for the
community now if a ruler really is
ruling that way then are they just
dominating people and exploiting them
and setting things up for their own
interests we all know people that do
that sometimes they do set things up
just to benefit